thank you
this migrant situation is one big
complication the Los Angeles city
council has voted to launch a criminal
investigation against Texas over its
migrant bussing problem
since June Governor Abbott has sent over
400 migrants to LA and that's in
addition to the more than 30 000
migrants abbots sent to democrat-lit
cities around the country an LA city
councilman said the callus disregard for
the lives of these families deserves
their full investigation that's kind of
true nothing shows disregard for human
life like dropping someone off in LA
meanwhile New Jersey's Democrat Governor
Phil Murphy is pushing back against the
influx of migrants to his state if only
had pushed back against that smell
coming out of Newark
the vine Administration has directed New
Jersey to receive migrants flooding New
York City but Murphy says New Jersey
simply doesn't have the resources to
handle them funny he previously pledged
that his state would welcome immigrants
so what's the bite Administration have
to say about all this well according to
White House spokesperson Karine
Jean-Pierre Biden has done more to
secure the Border than anybody else and
by anybody else she means no one
the president has done more to secure
the border and to deal with this issue
of immigration than anybody else he
really has June saw the single largest
month-to-month drop in lawful unlawful
border crossing because of the policies
this president put in place we've got a
record number of federal agents and
officers more than 24 000 working to
secure the Border because of the funding
this President secured
no surprise she failed to mention the
actual number of Migrant encounters at
the border
like loftus's monthly denim budget the
amount would shock you
Jim you know about this what's going on
there in New Jersey and you know the
governor's not being honest is he no I
live in New Jersey yeah he ran in 2017
he wanted to be a sanctuary state New
Jersey yeah then all of a sudden he
dropped it you know he just wanted to
get the votes and now they want to put
them in like Atlantic City Airport they
want to put them there and he's like no
we don't have the money for it yeah New
Jersey with the highest property tax in
the nation highest car insurance you
know tolls every five miles you go
gambling weed is legal but you don't
have any money for them yeah you know he
doesn't realize he goes migrants don't
you know he doesn't want migrants live
in New Jersey he doesn't realize that
the people living in New Jersey don't
want to live in New Jersey
plus they got all those guys with Farms
out there right doesn't Springsteen have
a farm Bon Jovi has a farm why don't we
put them on their Farms John Stewart's
got a farm Murphy's got a big fire they
all live on farms because they don't pay
taxes if it's a farm they put a couple
goats on the land they go where a farm
so we have to pay taxes they all do it I
think we ought to that's what we ought
to do we got to send them to the forums
cat
obviously the Situation's out of control
and the people who made it now they want
out of it it's happening here in New
York well yeah and and obviously I look
the busing of migrants is a political
thing it is political yeah but it's to
prove a political point that the other
side was just also being political when
they said hey we're a sanctuary City New
York is a sanctuary City it proves that
that was just political because I think
the bare minimum of being a sanctuary
for someone is allowing them to come
over like that's the bear that's the
bare minimum so you can't accuse other
people of being political like the way
that we've seen in La the way we're
seeing in New York if really they proved
that what you were doing was political
all along obviously this is something
that Congress needs to solve our
immigration system is not built for this
influx level of migrants but they're
having too much fun arguing back and
forth about it you know they can gain so
many points from their own for their
other side being like Oh you're a jerk
oh well look at the lawlessness but this
isn't having real effects on communities
and real people and they should actually
solve it but they won't as long as we
keep not expecting them to yes that's it
and what can we expect from them Emily
the red State Governors are doing this
desantised it in Florida when he sent
the migrants to Martha's Vineyard right
so they are doing it and they're scoring
not only political points but they're
bringing awareness to this issue and
then you have Democrats saying hey we
don't want them not in my backyard right
right so that I know honestly that
screams hypocrisy to me because it's the
blue states that want the open borders
but they don't want to face the
consequences of opening the borders and
then have the audacity it's called
Governor Abbott a racist for saying we
don't have the resources we cannot house
this many people and hey Cali why don't
you take them and they're like no no we
can't but you're bad if you don't do it
and to me I'm just like trying to think
of it break it down simplify it like a
first grade I'm like they welcomed them
allegedly
but they don't want them either but
we're the bad ones for not housing them
like just make it make sense for me it
doesn't make sense like you're saying
they're having way too much fun blaming
the other guy for their faults and I
don't get it breaking things down like a
first grader I'm gonna go to you Michael
my my time to shine
too many people Tom well walking across
land it's I like how it like so so these
illegal immigrants they've walked across
Central and South America to get here
and then in L.A they're like oh but a
bus ride from Texas that's inhumane
right if I'm Greyhound bus I'm offended
by that I'm like our buses aren't so bad
no no here's the other thing that I
wanted where the hell are all these
people coming from is there like a Wars
we should be stopping right because
isn't it like oh my life in my country
was too dangerous I need sanctuary in
America yeah where the is the conflict
like they just just like keep showing up
out of nowhere like what are they
running from I don't get that and I
remember a very wise man once said build
a wall and I'm all in favor of that
but like but like
I don't want a fence I'm not happy with
the fence anymore I want some Great Wall
of China right I want ample parking I
want a mall a casino I want those
windmill things on the top like real
close together so when anybody tries to
get over whack they get knocked back
wow it'll be like wipeout we could
televise it I'd watch the audience likes
your idea Michael hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else